the sound mixing stage is where pictures
on-screen become environments the
artists who work with sound the
craftsman whose talents transport us
into worlds both real and imaginary when
you leave from your seat when you turn
your head to see who's after you when
you cover your eyes and fears you still
feel like you're watching the movie it's
because of our nominees for sound mixing
and sound editing here the nominees for
achievement in sound mixing American
sniper John Wright's Greg Roode loft and
Walt Martin Birdman or the unexpected
virtue of ignorance john taylor frank a
Montaigne and Thomas Varga interstellar
Gary a Rizzo Greg Van Dekker and Mark
Weingarten unbroken John Taylor Frank a
Montaigne and David Lee whiplash Craig
man Ben Wilkins and Thomas curry and the
Oscar goes to whiplash
Thank You Academy for this honor we're
thrilled to be here
Gaming Gisele I don't quite know where
you are
there he is under extremely difficult
conditions you showed us the meeting of
leadership and under that leadership
creative a creative collaboration
blossom and that creativity is really
what helps us do our job
so thank you David Lancaster Helen
Esterbrook Jason Blum Cooper Samuelson
everybody at Blum house thank you pretty
big up here Thank You Stella Jeff and
Carol so our wives our parents are here
we're so happy you can all join us here
our wives we love you thanks Mike and
Dave my crew you guys are awesome our
entire team a technicolour thank you